Just a moment.
Just a moment. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, die 15. Ausgabe. Heute ein weiterer Rückblick, ein Rückblick in das Nachrichtengeschehen der letzten Wochen. Kein Versuch, furchtendlich zu sein, aber zumindest der Versuch hier mal mehr oder weniger regelmäßig die Geschehnisse da draußen zu reflektieren auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise. 15, wie gewohnt mit elektronischer Musik und wieder wie schon so häufig ein Mix aus der Sammlung des Erinnerungs-DJ-Mix-Netlabels. Gestern gab es die erste Netlabel-Party und es ist super gelaufen, ein großes Spaß gemacht, den Freimusik-Denis auch im Netz, dazu später mehr, denn Ende Februar die nächste Chaosradio-Sendung 110 wird sich ausgiebig diesem nettleben Thema wenden zu werden. So, aber eigentlich wollen wir uns ein bisschen unterhalten. Und ich bin ganz froh, weil ich bin nicht alleine, sondern ich habe mal wieder den Pavel dabei. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, ist ja schon eine Weile her, dass wir uns hier das letzte Mal gesprochen haben und heraus kam eine Testsendung.
Genau, die legendäre Testsendung.
Die hat einige Leute wirklich sehr verwirrt, aber das fand ich auch ganz gut. Aber es war vor allem ein sehr erfolgreicher Test, muss ich sagen. Also seitdem hat sich dieses Setup, was wir uns da in dem Abend zusammengeklickert haben, das hat bisher sehr gute Dienste geleistet.
Ja, ich habe aber auch viele positive Dinge gehört zu der Testsendung. Also viele Leute waren gerade begeistert von dieser Sendung in der Sendung. Also live mit dabei zu sein, wie eine Sendung gemacht wird und das während sie gemacht wird. Also das war dann schon auch offenbar für viele Leute, was ein innovatives Format ist, sozusagen die Live-Selbstdokumentation.
Ja, das ist sehr schön, zu sehen, welche Probleme wir da gelöst bekommen haben und welche wir vor allem nicht gelöst bekommen haben. Ah ja, das fällt mir gerade ein. Jetzt machen wir gleich noch mal ein bisschen von dem Flair der Testsendung, weil du erinnerst dich vielleicht noch, ganz am Ende der Testsendung habe ich eine Sache nicht hinbekommen und das war diese Verteilung von links und rechts. Aber jetzt weiß ich, wie das geht, weil ich habe mich auf dem Mischpult seinerzeit vertan. Jetzt drehe ich mich mal ein bisschen nach links, weil ich sitze ja auch links. Und dich drehe ich jetzt ein bisschen nach rechts, muss aber auch was sagen.
Ja, jetzt bin ich rechts.
Genau, aber nicht ganz rechts, sondern ein bisschen rechts.
So ein bisschen rechts, da bin ich ja gespannt.
Genau, und ich bin jetzt ein bisschen links. Und wenn er unsere Stimmen nicht auseinanderhalten könnte, dann ist er zumindest wohl uns holophonisch hier einsortieren soll. So, das Thema soll ein Rückblick sein auf die Woche oder auf die Monate. Wir haben jetzt hier mal so ein bisschen geschaut.
Genau, wirft doch mal ein paar Stichworte rein.
In der letzten Sendung hatten wir ja auch schon ein Rückblick auf den Kongress, aber jetzt klicken wir einfach mal auf den letzten Monat zurück. Und wir haben das hier nicht besonders gut sortiert. Also marschiere ich hier einfach mal durch die losen Notizen. Vielleicht etwas zum Start, was auch noch einen leichten Kongress-Bezug hat. Wir hatten ja auch auf dem Kongress diesen Blackberry-Vortrag von Phenoled. Und jetzt im Nachrichtenarchiv mal zurückgeblickt habe ich festgestellt, dass RIM, also die Firma, die diese Blackberries produziert, am 5.1. schon Patches rausgebracht hat.
Ja, dann hat der Kongress also geholfen, die Welt wieder ein bisschen sicherer zu machen.
So könnte man das natürlich auch sehen. Aber das ist schon auch keine schlechte Zeit. Eine Woche. Offensichtlich haben sie das wirklich ernst genommen. Ja, mit Sicherheitsproblemen gab es hier auch noch andere Probleme. Andere Kandidaten, die hier mal wieder zu kämpfen hatten. Microsoft. Da gab es eine Lücke im WMF-Dateiformat. Das steht für Windows Metafile. Und es ist eine Grafik-Datei, vor allem so eine Art Miniatur-PDF. Und dort war es möglich, Code mit zu injizieren, den das Betriebssystem ausgeführt hat.
Ja, eine ganz böse Geschichte. Mal eigentlich was ganz anderes. In diesem Meer der Viren und sonstigen Sicherheitslöcher, die ja immer in der Presse sind, ist das wirklich eine neue Dimension. Weil das nicht so aussieht, als wenn das Ganze durch einen Fehler entstanden wäre, sondern als wenn diese Lücke bewusst von irgendjemandem so dort hineingebaut worden wäre.
Genau, das ist das, was die Analysen gesagt haben. Diverse Security-Leute haben sich diese Lücke angeschaut und waren alle so der Meinung, na ja. Das ist nicht im eigentlichen Sinne ein Bug, der jetzt nur auftritt, wenn man hier und da den und den Wert übergibt oder hier mal so einen Nullstring mit reinwirft in den Programmcode. So was Einfaches, sondern ganz offensichtlich war diese Funktionalität einfach ein Teil des Dateiformats. Microsoft sagt ja selber, nein, so was gehört da nicht rein. Wir haben das auch nie geplant. Trotzdem stand so eine Weile die Bezeichnung Backdoor im Raum, dass es hier eine Backdoor handelt, worüber sich einige aufgerät haben, weil es ja quasi so impliziert ist, dass Microsoft das absichtlich hätte tun können. Was sie sicherlich nicht getan haben, denn diese Funktion ist nicht dokumentiert. Es gibt diese Funktionalität offiziell nicht und es gibt auch keinen Grund, wozu man das brauchen könnte. Trotzdem ist es irgendwie drin. Natürlich die Frage, wie hat es es geschafft, durch den QA-Prozess bei Microsoft durchzugehen und dann tatsächlich in ein ausgeliefertes Produkt zu kommen.
Vielleicht müsste man noch kurz sagen, was das praktisch bedeutet, welches Gewicht diese Hintertür hat, die ermöglicht es beispielsweise Bilder und Dokumente etwa in eine Word-Datei hineinzupacken, die dann Schadcode enthalten. Ja, dadurch kann man einfach so Dinge implementieren, wie dass vertrauliche Dokumente auf dem eigenen Rechner verschickt werden an irgendjemanden oder nach bestimmten Dingen gesucht wird oder Kennworte abgefangen werden. Also Dinge eignen sich sowohl für kriminelle Aktivitäten, ich glaube es ist jetzt auch irgendwo in The Wild eine kriminelle Seite bekannt geworden, die das ausnutzt. Und ja, eignen sich aber natürlich auch genauso zu Spionagezwecken oder zu anderen Überwachungszwecken oder für Sabotagezwecke als es ist.
Einfach mal eine Backdoor, man kann schön von hinten durchs Windows hinein marschieren und zahlreiche Funktionalitäten übernehmen. Interessant finde ich die Auseinandersetzung darüber, welche Windows-Versionen davon eigentlich tatsächlich betroffen sind. Ganz offensichtlich, und das hat Microsoft auch zugegeben, Windows XP und Windows 2000. Sie meinen auch, dass Windows NT davon betroffen ist und dem ist offensichtlich auch so. Allerdings stellen sie für NT keine Patches bereit, weil es ja nicht mehr supportet und man kann ja auch ein Upgrade machen. Und was noch interessanter ist, ist, dass Microsoft auch meinte, dass Windows 9x, also 95, 98, SE, ME und was da alles noch so kam, dieses alte Windows, dass es auch betroffen sei. Und das konnten allerdings diese Sicherheitsanalysten nicht feststellen. Also es gibt so ein Test-Tool, MICE ist der Name, der dann so gecoint wurde, also Metafile Injection of Code, lalala Code Elements oder so war der Witz an der Stelle. Und dazu gab es dann die passende Mousetrap-Software, die sozusagen versucht, die Mäuse zu fangen. Und diese Software ist halt bei Windows 95, hat sie nicht angeschlagen. Also der Test, um auszuprobieren und dieser Code ausgeführt wird, ist halt fehlgeschlagen und alle sind sich eigentlich ziemlich einig, dass Windows 95 davon nicht betroffen ist. Aber Microsoft ist halt andere Auffassungen. Machen da so ein bisschen Scare. So nach dem Motto, auch ihr habt noch Windows 95, hier haben wir aber doch was hübscheres, nimm doch mal das.
Ja, wobei ich kann da Microsoft durchaus verstehen, dass sie einfach irgendwann mal diesen alten Mist nicht mehr supporten wollen. Also da muss ich sagen, würde ich ihnen nicht notwendigerweise böse Absichten...
Nö, das ist sicherlich auch bei Apple da nicht anders. Meine Mac OS 9 Sicherheitslücken, das jagt natürlich auch keinem hinter dem Ofen vor. Aber die Verbreitung von Windows 95 ist also schon massiv und es sind ja auch meistens alles Maschinen, die nicht so ohne weiteres auch außer Betrieb genommen werden können, die man nicht so ohne weiteres auf das neue System überspielen kann.
Also ich weiß es nicht, also ich kenne mittlerweile nur noch sehr, sehr wenig Leute, die 95 oder 98 auf ihrem Rechner haben, also sehr, sehr wenig.
Ja, im Heimbereich mag das ja sein. Ich denke jetzt eher an so diese typischen Firmenlösungen. Du wirst das kennen, man kommt in irgendein Unternehmen, egal ob das jetzt Industrie ist oder was auch immer. Und irgendwo in der Ecke, in irgendeinem Büro-Netzwerk steht so ein Windows 95-Rechner, der tut halt so eine Sache. Zum Beispiel Faxgerät oder so etwas. Einfach so ein Bürodienst, den man irgendwann mal mit diesem Desktop-Computer implementiert, gelöst hat das Problem und dann lief das so. Und never change a running system. Und so steht es dann halt die ganze Zeit vor sich hin darum und funktioniert einfach. Und du könntest dieses Setup aber jetzt mal nicht so ohne weiteres auf einen neuen Betriebssystem installieren. Wahrscheinlich ist der System-Administrator der Letzte, der wusste, wie man mit dem Ding überhaupt konfiguriert ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon vor zwei Jahren gefeuert worden. Und es hat halt einfach keiner gemerkt. Und entweder geht irgendwann die Harte kaputt. Also solche Systeme gibt es halt. Es ist einfach in the wild. Und es gibt aber auch einen inoffiziellen Patch, der also nicht von Microsoft kommt, der diese Lücke auch schon gefüllt hat. Aber es ist halt nun mal so bei Windows 95 gibt es das nicht. Also es gibt dieses Problem nicht. Und trotzdem drängt halt Microsoft oder was halten da jetzt drängen nicht. Aber so befragt meinten sie halt, Windows 95 sei auch davon betroffen. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob sie das immer noch aufrechterhalten. Aber so war es zumindest am Anfang. Was auch noch ganz lustig ist, dann können wir das Thema vielleicht auch abschließen. Wine, diese Emulation, also dieses nachprogrammierte Windows für Unix-Umgebung, was manche Leute einsetzen, hatte diesen Fehler auch. Also derselbe exploit hat da auch funktioniert und die konnten sich das zuerst gar nicht so richtig erklären, weil sie das nicht wissentlich eingebaut hatten. Aber eigentlich bauen sie in dem Projekt überhaupt nichts wissentlich ein, weil sie die ganze Zeit nur den Code Reverse von ihrer Funktionalität her engineern. Sie behaupten, sie seien Bug-by-Bug-compatible. Das heißt, sie sind geradezu darauf angewiesen, alle Fehler auch zu machen, damit die Software auch problemlos läuft in der Emulation. Das hat auf jeden Fall Wellen bewegt. Zu Recht, wie ich finde. Was haben wir denn noch hier in unserer Nachrichtenlage? Sony macht von sich reden. Und zwar haben sie den Aibo eingestellt.
Ja, eigentlich traurig.
Hast du dem mal eine Hand gehabt?
Ich hatte mal ein paar Tage einen. Wir haben ihm Geschichtenvorlesen beigebracht. Wenn man ihm ein Märchenbuch hingehalten hat, hat er das Märchenbuch erkannt. Und dann hat er eine entsprechende Geschichte vorgelesen.
Oh, welche?
Es gab da verschiedene. Er hat dann das MP3 abgespielt. Und ja, das...
Und hast du deine Erklärungen, warum sie ihn eingestellt haben?
Tja...
Verkauft sich nicht?
Vermutlich nicht in so großen Stückzahlen. Ich meine, das Ding ist auch unglaublich teuer.
1500 Euro oder so?
Ja, weiß ich nicht zum Schluss, aber der hatte ja noch wesentlich mehr. Jedenfalls richtig doll teuer. Zwei, zweieinhalb... Ich glaube, am Anfang kostete der 5.000 oder 6.000 Dollar. Irgendwie so was, als der rauskam. Aber da steckt auch richtig viel drin in so einem Aibo. Das ist schon ein bemerkenswertes Stück Technik, was sie da reingebaut haben. Eine Kamera, Mikrofon, verschiedenste Sensoren, einen WLAN, eine Bilderkennungssoftware und dann natürlich extrem viele Servos, die die Beine und Kopf bewegen, eine ganze Reihe von LEDs, noch die Signale abgeben und das Ganze mit einer recht cleveren Software auch. Das Ding kommt bei Leuten schon an wie ein Hund. Vor allem bei Frauen hat es einen riesen Erfolg. Die sprangen auf und ab und oh süß.
Ist er einfach zu programmieren?
Kommt darauf an, auf welcher Ebene. Man kann sehr einfach so Dinge machen, wie wenn ich dir diesen Gegenstand zeige, dann führe die und die Aktion aus. Das kann man ohne Programmierkenntnisse machen. Man hält ihm irgendwas vor, klickt und dann führt er irgendeine Aktion aus. Also eine einfache, grafische Programmiersprache für simple Dinge. Damit kann man schon eine ganze Menge machen. Und dann gibt es, was auch nett ist, einen Fernbedienmodus. Du kannst vor deinem Laptop sitzen und siehst dann über WLAN. Das Kamerabild von der Kamera in der Schnauze und kannst mit ihm einfach rumrennen und ihn voll steuern. Das heißt, du kannst eben auch dann die ganzen Posen machen und Fötchen geben, während du ihn fernsteuerst. Und ja, es ist schon ein richtig nettes Stück Technik. Und es ist unglaublich, wie viel die da in dieses kleine Gerät reingepackt haben. Also das ist auch von der Miniaturisierung her und wie lange die Batterie hält, das ist ein echtes Stück Hightech, würde ich sagen. Und es ist verständlich, dass es so teuer ist.
Okay, aber jetzt wird es keinen mehr geben.
Ja, es sollen nur noch die Lagerbestände jetzt abverkauft werden.
Und soweit ich das gelesen habe, auch der Nachfolger, oder dieses andere Roboter-Modell, dieses Humanoid-System, was sie haben.
Ja, soll auch eingestellt worden sein.
Heißt das einfach, dass dieser Markt nichts hergibt, dass einfach die Zeit dafür nur nicht reif ist und sie im Prinzip jetzt nur ein Spielzeug für Wissenschaftler gebaut haben, die jetzt anfangen, sich diese Dinger zu kaufen?
Ich fürchte, es war einfach zu teuer. Es kann wirklich sein, dass sie einfach fünf Jahre zu früh dran waren.
Aber 2000, also ich sehe hier im Netz gerade so 2100 Dollar. Ist ja nun auch nicht so viel für so ein Gerät, oder? Naja, der Top kostet das gleiche.
Also der Nutzen, erst mal, es ist ein Spielzeug. Es hat nicht wirklich irgendein Nutzen, außer einem Unterhaltungswert.
Stimmt schon, das stimmt schon. Ja, Sony, was haben sie denn noch? Dann haben sie noch ein Reader Device rausgebracht, was über E-Ink verfügt, also elektronische Tinte, elektronisches Papier. Hast du damit schon mal was zu tun gehabt? Das ist ja seit längerer Zeit schon im Gespräch. Und so vor zwei, drei Jahren war das erste Mal schon absehbar, dass man das wohl irgendwann mal gebaut bekommt. Und jetzt gibt es halt diesen Sony Reader.
So, was macht der jetzt genau?
Der zeigt Bücher an. Das ist halt im Prinzip die Idee des elektronischen Buchs. Bloß das Besondere an dem Ding ist, dass er eben extrem wenig Strom verbraucht, um das Bild zu halten. Das heißt, nur in dem Moment, wo man wirklich das Display refrescht, verbraucht das Ding Strom.
Und wie ist die Auflösung und der Kontrast?
Tja, über den Kontrast kann ich wenig sagen. Ich habe so ein Ding nicht in der Hand gehabt. Das ist jetzt auf der CES vorgestellt worden und soll halt über eine gute Lesbarkeit verfügen. Ich bin mir auch nicht so ganz so sicher, wie sie das mit dem irgendwas war. Natürlich wieder mit DAM, um halt diese Bücher dort zu schützen. Also im Prinzip so ein bisschen der iPod für Text. Das ist eigentlich die Idee dahinter. Was durchaus interessant ist, weil um jetzt eine Webseite zu lesen, braucht man halt auch nicht mehr.
Solange sie das Kontrast- und Auflösungsproblem nicht hinkriegen, solange wird das nur ein armseliger Ersatz sein für Bücher oder bedrucktes.
Na gut, aber es ist halt nicht wie ein LCD-Display. Es ist halt jetzt nicht so ein komischer PDA, der von hinten beleuchtet wird. Und wenn es ein bisschen hell ist, dann kannst du nichts mehr lesen.
Also wir hatten ja neulich im Club die Auflösungsdiskussion, wie viel Auflösung sollte dein LCD-Display haben, damit man dort bequem lesen kann. So meine Meinung war, also mindestens 300, besser 600 DPI ist das, was man haben möchte.
Eigentlich das Gleiche wie auf Papier.
Aber eigentlich kamen wir dann darauf, dass wir eigentlich die 2.800 DPI gerne hätten, mit denen man auf Papier rastern kann. Dafür müssten die Pixel dann aber...
2.800 DPI, 2.800 Punkte pro Zoll, das gibt Papier her. Also Belichter-System, wie meinst du jetzt? Echt so viel?
Also das ist wohl irgendwie die Auflösung, in die Postkript rastert dann.
Na gut, Postkript selber ist ja auflösungsunabhängig.
Jaja, aber es gibt schon so, glaube ich, so was wie ein internes Limit, ein Genauigkeitslimit, mit der Postkript-Implementation...
Mit der Auflösung der Fließkummerzahlen und so. Okay, verstehe. Okay, na gut, aber 2.800, das wäre auf jeden Fall schon mal eine deutliche Steigerung. Das wäre dann, glaube ich, in etwa das 28-Fache von dem, was ich jetzt auf meinem Laptop habe.
Ja.
Das heißt, jeder Pixel könnte nochmal in 28 Unterpixel unterteilt werden.
Na, in 28 mal 28 Pixel. Also, ja, in rund 300 Pixel. Also überall, wo du jetzt ein Pixel hast, hättest du dann 300 Pixel.
Also auf jeden Fall kann ich mir vorstellen, dass dieses Gerät auf Interesse stößt. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Leute von Zeitungen genauso begeistert sind wie von Musik. Und daher wird es sicherlich nicht ähnliche Effekte haben. Aber es muss sich erst mal zeigen, ob das technisch überhaupt verspricht, dass hält, was es verspricht, ob es verspricht, was es halten kann.
Was haben wir denn noch für Themen?
Na, ich sehe die Firma Intel in den Nachrichten, die haben verschiedene Dinge getan. Zum Beispiel sind sie ihrer Intel-Inside-Kampagne jetzt losgeworden. Das verwenden sie jetzt nicht mehr, sondern irgendwas anderes Buschiges. Vor allem ist es ihnen natürlich gelungen, bei Apple Fuß zu fassen. Die neuen Macs, die dieses Jahr vorgestellt werden, werden ganz offensichtlich alle durchgehend nur mit Intel-Prozessoren verbaut werden.
Wobei das bisher, glaube ich, vor allem wirtschaftlich nicht so der große Punkt ist für Intel, sondern mehr image-mäßig, also von den Stückzahlen her, was sie da an Prozessoren loswerden, ist das sicherlich...
Das Image, aber es gibt sicherlich auch noch einen anderen Punkt, weil sie halt mit Apple unter Umständen gewisse Technologien besser durchsetzen können. Eine USB hat sich eigentlich auch erst mit dem iMac verbreitet. Vorher hatte noch keiner so richtig die Traute, da mal umzuschalten. Und ich will nicht sagen, dass es jetzt nur daran gelegen hat, aber es war ganz offensichtlich der erste Computer, der das hatte. Und Apple ist ja auch bekannt dafür, dass sie relativ früh neue Techniken einbauen. Die DVI vor allen anderen, SCSI vor allen anderen, Firewire vor allen anderen.
Das ist wahr. Also, dass sie Apple als Testlabor für neue Technologien...
Genau, zum Beispiel für ihr neues BIOS. Weil dieser PC, den Apple da baut, ist ja insofern identisch, als dass er das ganze Mainboard für Intel weitgehend selber gemacht haben. Das machen sie jetzt echt nicht mehr selber. Das heißt, sie bauen auch keine Custom Chips mehr, sparen sich damit ein bisschen Geld. Unter Umständen. Also, neben dem Imagegewinn können sie halt auch neue Technologien durchbringen. Weil jetzt sind alle erst mal damit beschäftigt, wie man Windows XP mit EFI, BIOS bootet zum Beispiel.
Auf jeden Fall muss Intel aber einiges tun, um wieder die Position zu erreichen, die sie mal in hat. Sie haben ja massiv Marktanteile verloren. In bestimmten Märkten. Und AMD ist da in vielen Märkten auf dem Vormarsch. Und auch die technologische Führerschaft haben sie nicht wirklich unumstritten. Ich meine, der Pension M ist ein netter Prozessor. Der ist relativ schnell allerdings. Leider nicht wirklich 64-Bit fähig. Und soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, sind auch die neuen Dual-Core Pension M nicht so ohne Weiteres 64-Bit tauglich. Ja, und das ist natürlich doch etwas unzeitgemäß. Weil ich hatte schon vor einem Jahr entschieden, also beim Desktop, als es mit dem ATLON 64 einfach mal gute 64-Bit-Alternativen gab, kam mir einfach kein 32-Bit-Rechner mehr ins Haus.
Aber der 64-Bit-Bedarf ist ja auch noch nicht so groß.
Na praktisch nicht, aber in vielen Anwendungen stößt man schon immer mehr an die 2-Gigabyte-Grenze. Es ist zwar noch erträglich, aber bestimmte Programme, das bearbeiten große Dokumente oder 3D-Modelle oder auch Spiele. Mittlerweile könnten ruhig mehr als 2 Gigabyte RAM gebrauchen.
Aber die Grenze liegt doch bei 4.
Ja, aber die sind nicht wirklich nutzbar von einem 32-Bit-Betriebssystem, weil man die oberen 2 Gigabyte meistens für andere Zwecke benötigt. Und was noch viel schlimmer ist, man hat halt eine Fragmentierung von virtuellem Speicher, die dazu führt, dass man praktisch, selbst wenn man oft nur einen 800 Megabyte großen Speicherblock gerne hätte, dass man den einfach nicht mehr bekommt. So, das ist halt auch ein Problem. Jedenfalls ist es auf jeden Fall kein Zeichen von Technologieführerschaft, jetzt mit einem Prozessor nochmal rauszukommen, der einfach nicht 64-Bit-fähig ist. Das zeigt, dass sie an der Stelle einfach...
Ja gut, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass sie nicht in der Lage wären, 64-Bit-Prozessoren zu produzieren. Das tun sie ja nun schon seit längerer Zeit mit der Titanium-Serie.
Ja, aber offensichtlich nicht für den mobilen Bereich.
Hat denn Intel überhaupt schon einen... Wie ist das mit dem 64-Bit-Befehlssatz? De facto hat sich ja jetzt der AMD durchgesetzt. Und gibt es schon einen Prozessor, der das auch implementiert bei Intel? Oder haben sie nur gesagt, dass sie das tun wollen?
Nein, den AMD-Befehlssatz, die Pentium 4s seit einiger Zeit, sind auch alle 64-Bit-fähig. Das ist auch ein Ding, was ich überhaupt nicht verstehe, dass Intel klammheimlich das eingeführt hat. Also ohne großes Tamtam über die Hintertür. Deswegen hast du es auch gar nicht mitbekommen.
Ich habe mitbekommen, dass Sie das tun wollten, aber ich habe jetzt nicht im Einzelnen mitbekommen, wann Sie damit angefangen haben.
Da heißt dann ein Prozessor Pentium 4 620 und der hat dann keinen 64-Bit und dann gibt es Pentium 4 840 und der hat dann 64-Bit. Also so, wie Sie es verheimlicht haben, dass jetzt 64-Bit Einzug hält, das ist kaum zu verstehen.
Aber du sagtest, Sie haben die Technologieführerschaft da an AMD abgegeben, das gilt aber nicht unbedingt jetzt für den Notebook-Bereich, oder? Weil die Prozessoren von AMD sind da doch deutlich mehr auf den Server-Markt hin ausgelegt.
Ja, aber auch AMD hat 64-Bit-Mobild-Prozessoren im Angebot. Und ich weiß nicht, wie es mit Dual-Core-Notebook-CPUs im Moment bei, aber ich meine, da wäre auch was gewesen.
Die Nachrichtenliste ist natürlich noch viel länger. Eigentlich müsste man das mal wöchentlich bearbeiten.
Ja, aber vielleicht kannst du ja noch ein bisschen mir was über ein paar nette neue Podcasts erzählen. Du sitzt doch da immer an der Quelle.
An der Quelle? In einer Quelle sitzen wir alle an der Internetquelle.
Aber du hast immer die bestgepflegte Abo-Liste.
Na ja, ich habe mir auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge angeschaut, worauf spielst du jetzt auf eine bestimmte Form von Podcasts an oder Podcasts im Allgemeinen?
Na, ich finde ja erst mal das Video-Podcasting-Phänomen persönlich so extrem interessant, aber ansonsten ändert sich unglaublich schnell immer. Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass das, was man vor einem Monat darüber wusste, mittlerweile schon wieder veraltet ist, dass sich die Dinge da wirklich überschlagen.
Ja, das kann man schon so sagen. Also es ist auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Dynamik in der Podcastwelt derzeit zu verzeichnen. Das spielt sich natürlich vor allem in USA ab. Dort gibt es erst mal eine ganze Menge an Podcasts, also auch die independenten Podcaster, sozusagen die, die jetzt diesen ganzen Trend angeschoben haben. Da gibt es einfach viele, also Sparten- und Nischenprogramm-Dedüxte. Da gibt es also wirklich für jeden mentalen Zustand mittlerweile auch den passenden Podcasts.
Hast du mal Beispiele für so alles Mögliche?
Na ja, es gibt Leute, die alte Radio-Hörspiele, Science-Fiction-Radio-Hörspiele in einem Podcast wiedergeben. Natürlich über alle möglichen aktuellen Themen reden, aber auch vor allem alle möglichen Formate ausprobieren. Es wird extrem viel aus dem Wohnzimmer gepodcastet, Pärchen-Podcast, der Podcast für irgendwie junge Mütter und natürlich zahllose Tech-Podcasts in aller Form für jeden Bereich mit und ohne Video, wobei der Video-Teil relativ langweilig ist. Interessant sind einfach die reinen wirklichen Audio-Podcasts und die entwickeln sich auch am besten. Was auch gerade zu verzeichnen ist, ist das Entstehen von Podcast-Networks. Das sind Allianzen, wo sich mehrere Podcaster unter einem Namen versammeln. Entweder ist es einer, der mehrere Podcasts startet oder im Falle von podshow.com, die bekanntesten sind durch den Adam Curry, der das so weitgehend mit angestoßen hat in dieser Entwicklung der Podcasts. Die versammeln jetzt gute Podcasts und versuchen, alles Mögliche damit abzudecken, um einfach so ein Portfolio zu haben. Nebenbei werden jetzt eine ganze Menge interessante Ideen ausgebrütet, wie man damit Geld verdienen kann.
Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an das Web 1995, 96, wo das Web anfing plötzlich so Dinge zu enthalten, die man erst gar nicht für möglich gehalten hat. Für mich war, ich glaube, 95, als wir in der Firma eine Kakerlakenplage hatten, habe ich das Wort Kakerlake in irgendeiner der Suchmaschinen, ich weiß nicht, ob es Alta Vista war damals, Google war noch nicht eingetippt, und so kam daraufhin unter anderem das Cockroach Control Manual angeboten, ein 55-seitiges PDF oder Postscript-File, ich weiß nicht, ob es schon ein PDF war, wo alles über Kakerlaken drin stand, wie man sie identifiziert, wie man sie am besten bekämpft. Und wir haben dann ja professionelle Hilfe geholt und das ging ohne großartig Gift, einfach nur mit irgendeinem modernen Blockstoff und irgendeinem ganz spezifisch wirkenden Gift. Also wir haben extrem wenig ausgebracht davon und eine Woche später waren wir sie los.
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob du jetzt sofort auch den Anti-Cockroach-Podcast finden würdest, aber ehrlich gesagt überraschen würde mich das nicht. Also die Dynamik hat die Podcasting-Szene auf jeden Fall, dass sie wirklich zu jedem Kram irgendwas findet. Derzeit ist es allerdings auch alles noch sehr im Experimentierstadium. Es gibt einfach zahlreiche wirklich verrückte Sachen in einer Podcast, wie ja, Wanzahnarzt ist live und so. Also es sind auch alles ganz interessante Einblicke in die Verrücktheit und es ist alles sehr persönlich, alles sehr privat, wenn es eben persönlich und privat sein soll. Aber es dehnt sich eben auch bis in die Medien raus. Die großen TV-Networks fangen jetzt auch alle an, Podcasting zu machen. Das heißt, sie bringen mindestens mal ihre Nachrichtenshows und das, was sie sowieso an Spoken-Word-Content haben, können sie natürlich relativ leicht recyceln. Cartoons kriegen extreme Aufmerksamkeit, weil Animation einfach ein Format ist, was sich im Videobereich super verkaufen lässt. Das hat man in den letzten Jahren gesehen, auch der Erfolg mit Pixar, der letzten Endes dazu geführt hat, dass Disney sogar Pixar kauft. Für einen unglaublichen Betrag. Was gehen die da aus, 7 Milliarden?
Wobei noch unklar ist, wer wen eigentlich gekauft hat.
Das ist wie mit Apple und Next. Das ist genau das gleiche Ding.
Und AOL und...
Was mit AOL? Na, der Merger damals. Mit Netscape meinst du, oder was? Ach so, mit Time Warner.
Genau.
Ja, ist völlig unklar. Steve Jobs ist jetzt halt der größte Aktionär von Disney. Und außerdem sind wichtige Positionen alles mit Pixar-Leuten jetzt besetzt worden. Das ist halt genauso, als Apple Next übernommen hat, dann haben auch die Next-Leute die Position bei Apple übernommen. Ist klar. Steve Jobs marschiert ein. Aber wir kommen vom Thema ab. Die Podcasts sind auf jeden Fall in beiden Bereichen sehr aktiv, also Video wie auch Audio. Interessant sind diese Modelle, wie sie sich das jetzt überlegen mit der Werbung. Weil die Hörer sind natürlich alle sehr sensitiv. Man hört auch Podcasts, weil es eben ein anderes Erlebnis ist, als das, was man aus Radio und Fernsehen kennt. Deswegen kann man jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres damit mit brachialer Werbung nach der alten Art anstoßen.
Ich bin da auch sehr skeptisch, was Werbung betrifft.
Ja, das sind viele, aber es wird auf jeden Fall ausprobiert. Es gibt so erste Advertisement-Networks, wo man halt seinen Podcast quasi anbieten kann. Die haben dann Werbung quasi vermitteln wollen. Ob das greifen wird, das wird man sehen, aber zumindest gibt es diese Bestrebung. Und die entwickeln wirklich interessante Ideen. So, dass die Werbung zum Beispiel automatisch eingeblendet wird in den Podcast, das heißt, man muss das gar nicht mehr selber reinschneiden. Man kann dann auswählen, wo es eingeblendet wird. Und dann kriegt unter Umständen derjenige, der diesen Podcast bezieht, beim Download auch eine andere Werbung in Abhängigkeit von seiner IP-Adresse und so ein Kram. Also sie sind wirklich schwer am Nachdenken.
Ich hätte ja noch eine ganz andere Idee, die mir da gerade so kommt. Also wenn schon Werbung, warum nicht dort auch so den Ansatz von unten zu machen und einfach Werbung für die Produkte machen, von denen man einfach überzeugt ist. Das heißt, man legt sich einfach auf, so sich selber drei Produkte für seine Sendung zu überlegen, von denen man absolut überzeugt ist und der Meinung ist, dass wenn mehr Leute das besitzen, die Welt ein besserer Ort sein wird. So und da halte ich es auch dann völlig legitim hinzugehen und diese Produkte zu promoten und sich dann darüber zu finanzieren, indem man halt vorher einfach aushandelt mit einem Herstellenden, mit einer Bezugsquelle und dann dieses Produkt auch zu einem entsprechend günstigen Preis vielleicht sogar den Leuten, die einen zuhören, anbieten kann.
Also genau solche Sachen laufen da gerade bei Podshow, insbesondere bei Adam Curry. Er hat selber im Prinzip angefangen in seinem Podcast, diese unterschwellige Werbung so spielerisch auszuspielen. Also wie immer, wenn er mal kurz aufstoßen muss, erwähnt er dann seinen Namen der Kaffeemaschine, redet die ganze Zeit darüber, wie großartig diese Kaffeemaschine für ihn dienst tut, aber er erwähnt halt auch nicht selten, dass er dafür sozusagen kein Geld bekommt, dass er es sagt, aber spielt halt so mit dem Ding so, bis irgendwie alle Leute angefangen haben, sich diese Kaffeemaschinen zu kaufen. Und dann haben wir heute auch Audio-Kommentare zurückzuschicken, wieder in die Sendung, wieder zurückindizieren, und jetzt hast du mich so verrückt gemacht, und wo soll denn das noch führen? Ähnliche Erfolge hatte so ein kleines Spielzeug, so ein Miniatur-Aibo, der sogenannte iDoc, das irgendwie auch so ein kleines Hündchen ist, was mal ganz begeistert vor sich hin blinkt, rumkläfft und Schwanz wedelt und deine Musik nachsingt und solche Sachen macht, wenn du Musik spielst, und kannst das irgendwie direkt in den iDoc an deinen iPod anschließen. Also bin ich echt keine Zielgruppe für solche Produkte, aber ganz offensichtlich finden das dann viele Leute auch toll. Und jetzt geht es so weit, dass die Leute anfangen, schon Musikstücke zu machen, wo irgendwie dieser ich, mein iPod und mein iDoc irgendwie besungen werden. Wir haben auf jeden Fall alle eine Menge Spaß, die ganzen Podcaster und die Hörer in der Interaktion miteinander, das merkt man richtig. Das ist, das haben einfach alle, finden es alle richtig toll. Es ist gute Laune und interessante Diskurse, die man verfolgen kann. Es wird einfach viel diskutiert. Es wird geredet. Man kann Meinungen hören und man kann endlich auch mal die Stimmen dazu hören. Es ist einfach ein ganz anderes Wahrnehmen. Auch die Tech-Podcast, die ich mir anhöre, die bestechen dann einfach durch ganz außerordentlich guten, auch in Amerika extrem erfolgreich ist This Week in Tech mit Leo Laporte, der auch schon lange Tech-Journalism macht und einfach eine sehr nette Art und Weise hat, diese Podcasts durchzuführen. Er hat auch noch ein paar Parallel-Podcasts, die auch sehr zu empfehlen sind, so einen Security-bezogenen, Security Now, und einen web-bezogenen Inside the Web. Das ist auch einfach so ähnlich, wie wir das machen. Man setzt sich einfach hin und redet darüber, was quasi auf der Agenda ist und nimmt sich mal ein bestimmtes Thema vor. Und dann hat man eben auch die Zeit, die man braucht im Podcast. Und gerade so im Dialog mit einer anderen Person, die eine Menge Plan hat, kann man eben einfach sehr viel besser Sachen herausarbeiten, als man das jetzt könnte, wenn man einfach selber einen Text für seinen Weblog schreibt. Ja, also es ist sicherlich auch nochmal wert, hier zu dem ganzen Podcasting-Phänomen auch nochmal eine eigene Sendung zu machen. Vielleicht auch nochmal eine ganze Reihe von Podcasts vorzustellen.
Klingt auf jeden Fall echt spannend. Wobei, hast du Zahlen, wie viele Leute eigentlich regelmäßig Podcasts hören, also von den Web-Usern?
Ich habe einige Zahlen gehört. Ich denke, dass niemand was Genaues weiß. Aber man kann schon ein paar Sachen ganz gut hochrechnen. Es gibt einige Podcasts, die sehr erfolgreich sind. Und soweit ich das aus Interviews rausgehört habe, kann man sagen, erfolgreich ist so ein Podcast ab 10.000 bis 50.000 Hörer. Wobei es bestimmt einige gibt, die sogar noch ein paar mehr haben. Also ich halte so irgendwas zwischen 50.000 und 100.000 für möglich. BBC hat gerade auch angefangen, eigene Sendungen zu podcasten. Die haben auch gerade eine Statistik veröffentlicht. Hab ich jetzt gerade hier nicht auf dem Schirm. Was auch schon nahe legte, dass sie so pro Tag locker auf, was war das, ungefähr 40.000 Downloads kommen. Nur jetzt nach dem ersten Monat. Also die Gesamthörerschaft ist sicherlich solide sechsstellig. Und mit jedem verkauften iPod verbreitet sich die Kunde noch weiter.
Aber natürlich noch ein riesen Potenzial, wenn man sich mal überlegt, dass vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, 30 Millionen Leute in Deutschland regelmäßig irgendwo am Internet sitzen. Und davon vielleicht gerade mal ein paar Hunderttausend Podcasts hören, ist da noch ein gewaltiges Potenzial.
Ich würde gar nicht mal sagen, dass die Leute, die jetzt schon am Internet sind, so die primäre Zielgruppe sind. Meiner Meinung nach ist die primäre Zielgruppe oder die viel interessantere Zielgruppe die Leute, die jetzt noch nicht am Internet sitzen, die einfach nicht an so einem Informationsdiskurs teilhaben, weil sie einfach mit dem Medium als solchen auch Schwierigkeiten haben. Weil manchen fällt es halt leicht, Informationen aus Text herauszunehmen, auch aus Unmengen an Text. Wenn ich mir anschaue, was mir täglich entgegenläuft, so viel Space drücken kann man ja gar nicht mehr. Und da überhaupt noch durch Querlesen halbwegs einen Überblick zu behalten, dazu braucht man eine Menge Training und auch eine gewisse Affinität. Und die fehlt einigen Leuten. Aber dafür haben sie eine ganz ausgesprochene Affinität für Sprache, für gehörte Sprache, für Radioprogramme, vielleicht auch Fernsehen in gewissem Maße. Auch da gibt es ja von Zeit zu Zeit mal eine gute Sendung. Aber der Bedarf nach diesem Subscriber-Modell. Im Web kann ich ganz problemlos mir alle diese Weblogs abonnieren und regelmäßig mit Nachrichten versorgt werden, die da sind. Mit dem Podcast funktioniert das eben jetzt genauso.
Das gibt es halt nicht in der Welt. Wäre das nicht auch mal eine nette UMTS-Anwendung fürs Auto, wenn einfach in meinem Auto ständig die aktuellen Podcasts einfach einlaufen, ohne dass ich was tun muss?
Ja, es gibt da schon erste Produktankündigungen oder so. Ich weiß nicht, irgendjemand hat das, glaube ich, schon mal gebaut. Auf jeden Fall stimme ich dir voll zu. Ich denke, meine UMTS braucht sowieso eigentlich erstmal seine Anwendung. Weil bisher sah noch niemand wirklich den Bedarf für größere Datenmengen mobil.
Ja, zumal die Bandbreite ja auch wiederum nicht so üppig ist, als dass ich da viel Spaß mit Real-Time-Streaming hätte. So wie sich das jetzt...
Wieder bei der Fußball-WM träumen sie ja wieder davon. Handy, TV. Wie heißt das? Ja, keine Ahnung.
Na gut, das sind ja Broadcast-Netze. Das funktioniert dann ja noch. Aber im Vergleich...
Ja, das funktioniert. Aber ich frage, ob wirklich das Interesse so groß daran ist.
Ja, und im Vergleich, ich meine, beim Podcast im Auto habe ich natürlich den Vorteil, ich kann die Bandbreite so nutzen, wie ich das gerne möchte und nicht, wie das Spektrum senderseitig aufgeteilt und verteilt wird.
Ja, und vor allem du kannst auch immer empfangen, wenn du empfangen kannst, aber du musst ja nicht in dem Moment auch hören. Live hat seine Vorteile, aber wird eigentlich nur für die wenigsten Sachen wirklich gebraucht. Das mag für das eine oder andere Format ganz interessant sein, aber das Allermeiste kann man wirklich non-live machen. Da ist Podcasting natürlich optimal als Technik.
Zumal man selbst Nachrichten halbstündig runterladen könnte und sich die dann anhören kann, wenn man ins Auto steigt. Also eigentlich wäre das eine ganz nette Sache.
Ich bin mir ganz sicher, dass das kommen wird. Ich denke, wir sollten jetzt hier an dieser Stelle auch unseren tollen Podcast mal wieder zu einem Ende führen.
Ja, ist auch, glaube ich, wieder ganz schön lang geworden.
Ist mal wieder viel zu lang geworden. Wir wollten da eigentlich nicht so lang machen. Aber mit dem Versprechen, demnächst mal eine Sendung ganz dediziert zu Podcasts zu machen und da auch vielleicht mal eine ganze Reihe von interessanten weiteren Podcasts vorzustellen. Verbleiben wir, der Tim und der Pavel.
Tschüss.
Und wir hören uns hoffentlich bald wieder bei Chaosradio Express oder auch beim Chaosradio.